Welcome to tips and techniques at startcooking.com.
I'm Kathy Meister.
There are six rules you need to follow to make perfect pasta.
Number one: Use a really big pot.
Otherwise, all the pasta will stick together when you cook it.
Number two: Boil lots of water.
At least four quarts for one pound of pasta.
Be sure to cover the pot...
...so the water comes to a boil more quickly.
Number three: Add two tablespoons of salt to the pot...
...after the water comes to a boil.
Number four: Put in your pasta and bring the pot back to a boil.
Number five: Be sure to give it an occasional stir.
And number six: Cook the pasta uncovered for no longer than it says on the package.
Give it a taste to see if it's tender.
Now, carefully, lift the pot with some potholders...
...and drain the pasta in the sink.
Don't forget the colander.
That's it.
Just add your favorite sauce and enjoy!